hi my name is Ashwin Donna Betty Raju
from Rochester Institute of Technology
and we'll be deep into talked on what we
managed to accomplish with in the trivia
trapezoid using unity Linc
hi to everyone knew who didn't attend
the last talk so I'm gonna be talking
about the Caribbean trapezoid and what
we managed to accomplish using unity
link to create you know it's wonderful
sci-fi adventure for students to learn
so my name is Ashwin Donna pathy Raju
over there is Jael and Jetson also
suited with this project as a non man's
are I'm a fifty year game design and
development student pursuing a master's
in that field abroad Chester institute
of technology and I'm gonna trip over
that all right um and so I'm excited to
share what we learned so for those of
you who didn't attend the last talk I'll
give a brief rundown and what the
Caribbean trapezoid actually is so
simply put it's um it's reality
multimedia platform designed to create a
comprehensive computational learning
experience you know we can use all the
big buzz words we want basically we
wanted to use music and games to help
students learn how to think
computationally well also just having a
fun time doing so so we wanted to go
beyond the plastic idea of you know 2d
turtle graphics that's been a staple of
computer science programs forever and
sort of give them a neat visual way to
see what they're learning and have a
tangible idea of what it all actually
does so to that extent we used Unity
link which allows us to at the time was
an unreleased technology that allowed us
to bridge the gap between wolfram
mathematica and the Wolfram language and
the Popular Unity game engine which is
one of the most popular choices and one
that I personally know as a team
development student so since it was an
unreleased technology that we basically
had gotten the pre-release codes for we
we were basically on the cutting edge of
this I don't know about many of you but
if I don't know the answer to a problem
my first instinct is to doodle it that's
not entirely possible when you're using
a technology that hasn't been released
yet so we ended up getting very good at
figuring out on creative solutions to
the challenges we were able to find that
we were able to just figure out looking
at documentation then looking at the
examples that we'd been given so
one of the first such problems that we
had run into was that you can't directly
invoke a function in a Unity function in
a c-sharp in Mathematica you can't just
say here I have this unity script I want
to call this this method and pass in
this data to it so that it can do
something so you know early on in the
planning stages I'm coming from the
unity side of things and this toss made
me know quite a bit of stress I can't I
can't invoke any of this code I want to
write to you know have the turtle move
in a linear fashion or do any sort of
animation or things like that so we we
stopped and we started thinking what did
we actually need it to do what did we
actually need out of this code what did
we need unity link to be able to do we
needed to be able to send and receive
some kind of data from you know from the
Wolfram language to unity we wanted to
tell the turtle to move forwards a unit
or do an animation or turn around
update its UI things like that so what
one thing that you can really do easily
in unity link is set component
properties so if we wanted to say pass
an array of data long
well we can just create an array of data
you know a double matrix of data really
that we can then set via the Wolfram
language and unity link and the thing is
is that unity then can be watching for
that data to change and the way it would
go about watching whether that data is
changed is by we had another variable a
boolean that we would say which you can
see there is a has changes so when that
variable is flipped you can see it you
know it dumps it to the console so that
we can make sure that we're getting the
right data and it processes the array
and then turns the boolean off again
because that boolean is only ever
flipped by Mathematica we by design
constraint we're able to ensure that we
the the array was always only ever set
by Mathematica as well that we could
found no this couldn't keep happening
and
with this witness it figured out we were
essentially able to come up with a vast
array of commands that our students
could use we can have the turtle move in
all three apses I oh it's an Amber Alert
ah okay wonderful so where was I
we were able to make the turtle move in
all three axes rotate however we'd like
him to we were able to implement an
array of like UI commands so that you
could reset his state you could reset
his rotation we were able to implement
to sort of level loading where you could
generate a series of goal posts in
Mathematica that students would have to
get the turtle to move through an order
and pass that array that data down to
unity so that it would then load those
dole posts and render them in a fashion
where they have a circle and a number
and stuff so the students to then you
can you can sort of see the educational
challenge of giving the students a
problem of move these goal posts in
order through in order and we were able
to all do this just by figuring out this
unconventional solution to how do we
send data down in a way that unity can
pick up through its own update loops and
whatnot so another problem that we ended
up running into a little bit was that
unity linked by its nature and even now
in the version 12 release as I
understand it you still need a unity
project in order to use unity Lane you
cannot create a build of the executable
that can connect to the Wolfram kernel
so this wasn't as much of an issue for
us once we stopped to think about it
because our students will be ok
especially as unity as the Unity game
engine is free to be able to just open
up this unity project we send them and
share it but it did pose a bit of a
challenge because we also wanted to be
able to hide some of the stuff that they
don't need to worry about from their
view but we decided ok we'll just tell
them if they want to see how this all
works they can do so but we don't have
to worry but for now you don't have to
worry about it you can send these
commands through the Wolfram language
and feel free to explore if you like
something we ended up running into was
that well as we were developing
in this project we wanted to be able to
create these different levels create
these different scenes and you know have
a little scene for testing out animation
without having to load up the paid you
know very large main game scene but we
wanted Mathematica to be able to
synchronize to the start scenes so that
you defined all the variables that
needed to update and change and things
like that so we ran into a similar issue
of well we can't do seen them as of 11.3
we couldn't do scene loading through
Mathematica so we ended up engineering
this game objet that by design would
show up on every scene that we would
basically flip the variable a variable
property of and so Mathematica would
check whether this variable was telling
it to hold up we're not in the start
scene yet please wait and then it would
go to sleep for a couple of seconds and
then try again we just seen loading can
be difficult and by engineering this
solution we were able to make it so that
when Mathematica tried to connect unity
it would always be able to unity would
always hop over to the start scene so
that the connection could complete
successfully and both a kernel would
wait and unity would transition and it
would operate well we also ended up
designing two modes that students could
use in their exploration of the stain we
told one of it one of them linked mode
which is this sort of thing I've been
telling about where you can send
commands and move the turtle around and
do stuff like that and we also had what
we called cinematic mode which we might
have which you know we're planning to
add like a story more of the story to
with voice acting and a sort of
narrative tale but we also wanted it so
that in this cinematic mode where you
have direct control in the Unity engine
itself which is also useful for just
making sure that the scene we've created
works well in game how do you make it so
that you don't have to worry about any
mathematical commands coming in and
interpreting so that isn't just like oh
we have a boolean flipped in unity don't
process anything that comes in from the
array I showed you earlier we also
needed to tell Mathematica
so that a student might would know oh
right I selected cinematic mode I
shouldn't be trying this so we ended up
sort of doing the same thing in Reverse
we had a variable that would be changed
by unity but would be watched by
Mathematica whenever it tried to we had
it so that when you called the start
command that would try and connect it
would wait for you to select the style
of bots whether you were in link mode or
cinematic mode and then based on your
selection here it would flip a variable
that Mathematica would be watching for
and only then with that execution of
that start command finish on the
Mathematica side so that it would know
what stated was and it would flip a
boolean behind the scenes and none of
the commands would execute so another
thing we wanted to do is provide all
sorts of controller support for students
to be able to sort of visualize things
because a lot of people nowadays are
familiar with light and spots
controllers in the light so we wanted to
be able to use those to help further the
MIT's reality part of our MIT's reality
platform so we basically used
Mathematica as full controller
integration in order to support ps4
controllers at spots controllers in the
light and have those setups that they
can send so that they would both in a
dynamic module display what commands you
were sending by moving your joystick
forwards you were sending a Ames move
forward command and then you could also
send those straight down so that we
weren't even just using the built-in
unity controller support but we were
doing it through Mathematica in Part B
just to see whether we could but also
because it was something we thought that
uh haha no so the third time now I
should really keep touching just moving
my touchpad every few seconds just to
show that we could and also just so that
students could start thinking okay if I
want to do this well when I you know
move these controllers in order it's
showing me a list of the commands that
it would process oh I can just type
those to solve this challenge without
using the controller as well we're also
working on Wii mote support if you're
here at the last talk professor Jackson
mentioned that there would be sort of
dolphin
the kids to play with with wearables and
stuff they have a nice convenient pouch
you can put a Wii mote into so we
started exploring whether we could use
remotes in Mathematica to Unipol
accelerometer data use the speakers to
make dolphin sounds etc as it turns out
at least on Windows while windows can
pick up a Wii mote via bluetooth it
doesn't actually understand the input
it's sending so I ended up designing a
ws tp-link program that would connect to
these Wii mote drivers using the Wii
yourself library and would also create a
and also send that data up to
Mathematica so that we could pull it and
connect there and be passed forward into
unity so it's still a bit finicky we're
still working out some of the bugs on
that so it's not really ready for a demo
yet but it's it was we have the data
coming up to Mathematica but the
wiimotes we have are a bit old and end
up just breaking on stage so we thought
it was better not to display that so Oh
so moving forwards our plans are to
fully integrate the wiimotes into the
whole MIT's reality systems so that kids
can play with the dolphins and see that
display as a little song to dance
routine on the screen we want to add
some more generative content to the
level using Mathematica to create you
know procedurally crafted choral or
interesting schools and AI behavior and
things like that as the class move class
that this is being used in moves forward
if there's any commands the students
request that you know they need like oh
hey I would like to diff I could do this
we'll move forward adding those we want
to work on story mode a bit more and
we're definitely doing to continue
working on this you know over the next
summer and over that the school year and
stuff like that so thank you I'm I'm not
quite done yet I'm gonna start showing
some demos and some of the actual stuff
here but that's most of the PowerPoint
so we created a riff raft package that
holds all of our commands in all of our
unity lanes integration so that students
weren't so that this could be used and
say a computational essay with just an
initialization cell at the start and
things like that so I'm just gonna go
ahead and run all those so load amps is
almost a wrapper around the Unity open
function that allows you to just load up
unity from a project it passes in the
right folder that it figures out because
of where it's always saved in relation
to the riff-raff package it also does
some basic initialization of variables
and it needs to do and so I also load a
MIDI file that we've pre created using
Mathematica I believe so that I can show
you how we have song and dance type
stuff implemented so we hit start on the
unity project and from there we can
start this connection I was already on
the start scene so it's not visible but
actually let me start from not the start
scene just to sort of show you what I
mean there but I'll start from main so
if I were to start unity and any scene
that I wanted we solved a
synchronization lock problem by
basically being able to and you can see
this log on the right here but it's
starting the connection it's connected
to unity it's found that the process
exists it tells it it tells unity to
switch to the start scene and it does so
automatically it then awaits the choice
of start mode you know as I mentioned
before link mode and cinematic mode can
all be used for various purposes in this
case I'll use link mode I may also
connect my controller as that starts up
so now we've started up in link mode so
in this state the turtle won't do
anything by itself you can you know
press WASD or use the controller in
unity all you like it won't do anything
because in this state it's waiting for
commands from Mathematica so we have a
delayed execution model where students
can execute a number of commands in
order no build them into this list in
this in the behind-the-scenes so it's
only ever sent over when you we add
stitute this aimed at secure command
here so in this case I'm just going to
tell amps to move forward five units one
after another and send that data down so
you can kind of see in unity but it's
sent that data over and Ames will you
know swim forwards five units you can
see it updating in this movement history
which is scrollable etc there's always
there's also of course like reset aims
if you want to reset its position or
things like that you can imagine that
being useful between scenes or between
exercises which is just another type of
command that gets sent over we can also
I've been told there's no speakers so
this will be playing a midi song from
mathmatica as it synchronizes with unity
but we can all have Malanda ideas so you
can sort of see the patterns on the back
of aims changing that is in
synchronization to the midi song that's
currently playing i could probably put
it up on my speakers but uh i'm not sure
that's fair to any of the people
listening from the video but uh so this
this can be created and there's a whole
set of lectures about what these
patterns represent and how they really
relate to the piano keyboard and things
like that that will be having our
students do but because the students
will be able to basically craft these
sounds themselves and pass them over
they can kind of they get to kind of see
the dances and songs they create
speaking of dances there's also
animation we can run right now and
don't really mean anything they're sort
of just we haven't actually named the
animations yet to like dance left or
dance right they're just used the
alphabet for now because our animator
has a bit of a sense of humor there but
if we run and you can see that we can
send a command and similar to any of the
other commands it does a little flip and
as it turns out K is a flip in one of
the other axes so if I were to run that
he does another spin so once we actually
get the proper names for those that'll
be a lot more usable for the students
and that's that's a lot of it oh there's
also the controller I can't believe I
forgot about the controller that's why I
plugged it in so if we connect the
controller let's hope this works no I
didn't I didn't that whoops oh no there
we go alright so if I push forwards on
the joystick you can kind of see that
it's saying oh yeah you're moving Ames
forward one so I can do that in any of
the directions and it will par set I can
turn the other joystick to change his
angle so you can see there's like
multiple commands here and if I tack and
you tap any one of the back bumper keys
it will actually send those commands
that are currently active so you can see
that it's sent multiple commands you
know turn a couple of times and then
move forwards things like that so if
that always if that gets you know
confusing and the student has managed to
run themselves into the ground or
something there's always commands you
can send you can use the start or select
we defined as you know resetting
rotation or resetting the whole scene or
things like that we've made it so that
you can change the speed of the turtle
through a named speed command eventually
get rid of the dynamics else I don't
actually that absently push the joystick
and have something run but we can do
like we can get speed or just pass in a
new speed of say you know 25 units a
second so then if we were to tell Ames
to move 5 units forwards
well he'll end up going quite fast
you know sailing through this mysterious
underwater Caribbean trapezoid so
there's all sorts of neat little things
that are available in the unity scene
that we're adding to it more and more as
we get more models in and more content
created for students to explore and as I
said there's a story mode that'll be
coming in and we hope this will be
useful for crafting a you know a fun way
for students to learn because they can
actually see all the stuff that's
happening on the screen in a unity
pop-up as it were so uh that's pretty
much all for me thank you for coming and
there's the five minute march so I'll
take any questions if you have any